with Alex Pier Yi told you best face off
of all time it was so intense straight
up two Samurai Warriors dude two Savages
I thought Alex won the first round
especially with the leg kicks that was
an issue for Yuri and that definitely
controlled the chaos of Yuri as well he
landed some good punches but overall I
thought Alex did did very well there and
then in that second round you know The
Knockout happened with Yuri as far as
the stoppage Yuri was kind of out on the
feet and then he was completely out when
he fell down so I can see how he could
see that and stop it especially when the
guys in Mount I didn't have an issue
with the stoppage Yi also said I was out
it was a good stoppage so if the fighter
says that there's no story here there's
no narrative early stoppage if the guy
inside the otgon who's taking the
punishment goes I was out y'all got to
stop cuz he said he was out all good to
the other extent of that it is a world
championship fight yes so you kind of
got to let it just to be sure let it go
a little longer